[Applause]
it hurts
it hurts not gonna lie
[Music]
here's here's the t fam a little while
ago i made a video about william
faulkner and
in doing so i looked at reddit to see
what
else was out there recently about
faulkner blah blah blah was other people
making videos i stumbled upon
a post in r slash books
it has a good amount of likes it has
about three and a half
thousand upvotes i have to say the title
of it took me off guard
just just a little bit i read as i lay
dying by faulkner
and it is the worst most meaningless
wretched trash i've ever had the
displeasure of reading
some of you may know that william
faulkner is one of my absolute favorite
writers of all time
i think he's a [ __ ] genius and i a
lot of people think he's pretentious
and that's fine because those people
they're just missing out
they're missing out on something great
that's how i feel about it it's not like
i'm saying faulkner should be for
everybody
i really don't think that i think
faulkner isn't a lot of people's taste
and that's
totally totally understandable a lot of
it is
confusing and hard to understand and
takes some effort but
this just it made me almost smile with
the kind of
intense hatred and passion that this
person feels for faulkner because it
reminds me
of the intense hatred i felt for
faulkner when i was forced to read
azelai dying in high school
so i feel like in a sense i relate to
where this person is coming from
from this post but also i just think
that they are jumping the gun a little
bit they need to take a step back
and possibly give faulkner another shot
so this is what this person has to say
about faulkner and they are really
trying to tear him a new one i read this
book for school
my professor used it as an example of
post-modern literature
first off that's not a good professor
because i think most people would say as
they lay dying does not qualify as
post-modern
most people would call it just modern
those terms are hard to define you know
i'll i'll let it slide
i'll let it slide just this once as much
as i really adore a lot of postmodern
works
this trash novel was almost enough for
me to denounce the entire
movement okay all right it's not like
faulkner was part of some
movement if anything he was part of a
movement of southern writers of the time
he wasn't part of any post-modern
movement there's no reason to denounce
post-modern
literature because you hated azalea
dying it's so poorly written in every
single way
not a single choice faulkner made while
authoring this crap was a good one
it's just like your opinion man okay my
professor told the class that apparently
faulkner said that to fully understand
his books you have to read them
four times uh someone in the comments
pointed out how he didn't
really exactly say this no faulkner
i'm not going to do that i like that i
like the attitude you know
just like uh-uh no faulkner's trying to
force this person
to read his books just like no i'm not
gonna i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to read your [ __ ]
over and over again like i'm studying a
religious text until it makes sense
if it takes that much energy and effort
to understand
whatever the hell you're going on about
then maybe your writing isn't some sort
of avant-garde
brilliant work maybe it's just nonsense
that people stare at long enough until
they convince themselves that there's
meaning
because otherwise they cannot justify
wasting that many
hours of their precious life alright i
feel slightly attacked
but i think this is a bit extreme you
may not like faulkner it may not be your
taste
but to say that people who appreciate
his writing
are just deluded and are trying to
convince themselves there's meaning
because they can't justify wasting that
much time on his writing it's just like
i wasn't forced to read i was forced to
read as ellie dying i didn't love it but
when i enjoyed faulkner it wasn't
because i was forced because i was just
wanted to read it i want to pick it up
and enjoy it i didn't give a [ __ ]
you know i already didn't think highly
of him it was just like whatever you
know i'll give it a shot
for [ __ ] sake there's a chapter in
this book that only includes the words
my mother is a fish yes i get that it's
supposed to be a five-year-old trying to
understand that his mom is dead but it's
so [ __ ] clear that it's being written
by some pretentious dick
trying to pretend to sound like
five-year-old faulkner's head was
pressed
so far up his own ass he couldn't be
asked to try to actually write a decent
child character and so just made a
bizarre
abstract idiot
i'm so sorry vardaman poor poor boy
poor boy he's just a bizarre abstract
idiot
first off and i like this about the
comments in this the post
because a lot of people were defending
my mother as a fish even people who
haven't read the book because they're
just like that sounds [ __ ] dope
just like a chapter that's just my
mother is a fish that's literally it's
so cool
what what can you hate about that
vardaman is a kid
he's a weird kid but he's not an
abstract idiot he's
he's trying to process his mother's
death er which is a
in a very bizarre situation first off if
you haven't read as ellie dying uh give
it a shot
it's it's pretty good but and if you
don't want to read it if the style's not
for you then read
like a summary of it because it actually
it has a story it's interesting the
characters are
developed and clear and unique but i'll
save that for at the end let's continue
also one of the characters in this book
was a girl that gets pregnant it's so
poorly written
that i one genuinely didn't realize the
character was a girl till
three-fourths of the way through the
book and two had no idea that there was
a sex scene in the book
you can you know that faulkner wrote
other books that you can go see like he
he didn't write all of his books like he
wrote as a lay dying a lot of it is
confusing some of it's confusing and
written in a way that's
transformative of these experiences
faulkner could write
with more standard prose it's not that
he was just writing poorly it's just
that he was writing differently
and that's the kind of attitude we need
to have about these things i don't think
we should be so judgmental
apparently faulkner also would write his
books all in one go
and wouldn't really go back and edit and
would also write his books in a very
short time span
this is incredibly obvious to anyone who
has tried to write a story quickly and
didn't think it
through all the way yeah faulkner
bragged about how fast he wrote azalea
dying how it just all came out of him
the idea that he didn't edit his work
can be so quickly fact checked like you
can
literally just pick up any any book read
any article we have his manuscripts like
we know that he
extensively thoroughly edited his books
like it's just
and then they share a quote from the the
novel daryl maybe
i think this may be daryl's quote
anyways the author of this post says
this means nothing i don't care how many
times i have to read it to understand
i don't care what eternal truths or
profound mystery is being shared
this is unacceptable unacceptable and
the fact that his
editor didn't immediately hold faulkner
at gunpoint
until he removed this garbage is the
greatest
dereliction of duty in a human history
in human history that's the greatest
dereliction of duty that's
honestly props beautifully worded i i
totally disagree with this
the person writing this post that's just
funny i feel like the young boy yelling
that the emperor is naked faulkner is
bad people
we can all stop pretending that he's
brilliant because we're afraid of being
called dumb
thank god i've been so afraid of looking
dumb i can finally this person is
freeing me
okay he's reminding me faulkner is bad i
can say it also
for all you people who are going to
suggesting i try another book of his oh
i did
i won't i will not give this fool
another second of my life
this book was so bad it completely
poisoned the well and if this post is
too choppy and poorly thought out to
make sense to you or if you disagree
please re-read this post eight times
while listening to
blue by eiffel 65 backwards and reciting
the lord's prayer if you do that then
you will be able to understand my
brilliance
this is so [ __ ] dumb i mean
i mean the only people who are going to
like this are people who haven't
who've been forced to read faulkner in
high school on
first glance just think that he's
overrated i have no problem with that
if you aren't into faulkner style that's
fine some of the responses
go read ulysses next yeah sometimes
people confuse
i didn't like this with this is bad i
never liked faulkner by the way yeah
yeah you don't have to assume there's no
value in it whatsoever
i don't know i mean i honestly arguing
against this it just feels like well
this just feels like a very immature
reaction to faulkner like yeah this is a
very strong opinion
and that's totally fine to have you
don't have to dismiss other people for
enjoying faulkner you don't have to
claim there's absolutely no value in
something
yeah this is just stupid like i honestly
i'm just doing this for fun because this
was just
it's just a stupid thing it irked me a
little bit that i got so much traction
a lot of people were kind of venting
about faulkner which is
it's fine i really think that faulkner
is not taught
well in high school and probably
shouldn't be part of like the high
school reading because
as i lay dying that it's just that's not
the time in high school to read that
honestly and
if there is faulkner to read in high
school maybe some short stories
light in august something that's not as
[ __ ] out there as
as i lay dying which is just like a
[ __ ] freak show of a book
let's be real as ellie dying is weird as
[ __ ] it's supposed to be
and when you try to pull it out of its
context of being just a weird [ __ ]
ass book and you start to look at it in
like an
academic way or try to standardize it in
school curriculum then it loses that
thing and it just becomes like an
object of intense frustration for high
schoolers which is what it was for me
and what it is for a lot of people and i
feel for these people who
hate faulkner because of this defining
experience of
of hating as i lay dying i wish that it
didn't have to be that way well this was
a
fun exercise in misery makes me a little
sad but it's just kind of [ __ ]
hilarious too i hope you enjoyed me
reading that reddit post if you like
seeing me suffer
at the hands of random people on the
internet you can watch more of my videos
and uh thanks for watching
yeah william faulkner